first of all what was the the germ of
the story and and getting this off the
ground or what made you want to return
to that world yeah a lot of people were
like why did you wait thirteen years but
we had no plans to go back we've you
know you spent four years making any of
these animated pictures in four years
with fish is a long time and so when we
finished Nemo we we thought we were done
and it was it was a self-standing movie
and moved on do robots and go to Mars
and they wanted to put the movie out in
3d Finding Nemo in 2011 so they had us
come watch it and I hadn't watched it in
years and I suddenly had a sense of
objectivity that I never usually have
with my films I got to see it's sort of
like an audience member and I walked out
of the theater going what door he's
gonna completely get lost and forget
Marlin Nemo she won't be able to get
back she doesn't know where she's from I
know because I wrote her I knew she had
the sense of abandonment this hole in
her that wasn't complete that she needed
closure and it bothered me I couldn't
drop it yeah so he he said that and it
was it was again he doesn't say those
things lightly
I think you could tell it bothered him
as a writer I think and as a director
and them so then we finished up the
movie we were on and that kind of kept
percolating and almost four years ago to
the day almost like we pitched the idea
to John Lasseter and he was like yes
please finding - yes
so you're coming back to this and after
some time and live-action which even
though it's live-action you're dealing
with a lot of visual effects and stuff
so I assume that that for you it wasn't
that far of a stretch it took just as
long yeah exactly so you're in
live-action you come back it was there
something about coming back to animation
that you go oh I'm really happy to be
back with this part of this business I'm
just wondering if there was something
that I mean to be honest the thing that
hits me when you ask that it was just my
family it was just the people I have
learned to make movies with that I've
started I've created a unique culture
with up north and I've spent 25 years of
my life you know depending on creatively
to to make stuff so that was always
comforting but it's I I must admit I
fell in love with the pace of live
action
it is is it's fast its spontaneous it's
reactive the animations the opposite it
is planning you do have a god-like
control but there is it's like making
movies in slow motion though there's a
patience that you have to kind of find
again to make to make it things in
animation you have such specific
characters that seem like they're
absolutely the perfect fish or creature
so where did you find those the new
characters some of them came just from
knowing the setting like I think we knew
early on that it was going to be
northern California coastline and so
that kind of dictated you know otters
and sea lions and loons I mean there's
there's certainly species that kind of
just exist in the northern California
coastline so that started it and then we
kind of from there went with exactly
what you said which is like what is what
are these what creatures do we want to
have in these movie because they are
just so charming when they just in
nature I mean the beluga whale is
ridiculous I don't have you ever seen
one in real life you can't stop watching
it basically looks just like that I
don't even think we caricatured him all
that much I mean he's got a goofy grin
and a big head and they jiggle like
hard-boiled eggs remains we all sharks
is just these giant graceful they're the
largest fish technically in the sea and
Tomita just like a giant Muppet in there
and then there's just the thought of
that talking to a tiny little blue tang
that just that was the sword or the
octopus was necessary for all kinds of
reasons partially just because octopuses
still can't believe I don't know how to
say the plural of octopus octopuses are
cool and they're escape artists and in
real life again they're so smart and you
can watch what they do and the only
thing they can't section 2 is astroturf
fun fact from my point of view film
history Pixar is kind of continuing the
the concept of character actors because
you have all these characters that get
their own little beat you know that
doesn't happen very often in live action
but in Pixar movies you have not gerald
and you have the little crabs and you
have all these little characters that
you take the time it's almost like they
have their own whole world and they have
their own whole story and they're so
fully developed how how do you allow how
do you create that or how do you allow
room for that well I think
some of that is the benefits the
benefits of time I mean we spend 3 and a
half years minimum developing a story we
basically in in live action I think
what's more common is somebody privately
alone in their their their their room
somewhere have pounded out many drafts
of a script until they think it's at
some place where they want to show it to
somebody and then maybe goes through a
couple more drafts with some executives
or people attached to it and then it's
usually you know something you feel it's
you can go shoot we invite everybody in
at the blank page and so it's a little
bit more like theater we're like we're
work shopping for three and a half years
this play and we're putting it on every
four months we board everything that we
write we go ultimately no finding Dory
was ten drafts and each draft we board
the entire film we scratch
use our own voices and put up you know
music pre-existing from either other
movies we've done or something just to
kind of get a sense and we put that play
on every four to six months for three
and a half to four years and then as we
cast we can start to sort of mold our
writing on our rewrites to the actors
that we have to play off their strengths
and it gives us a lot of time to think
about and take advantage of the
characters we've cast whether they're
fish or whether they're toys and the and
the voices and find the economy I mean
usually when something takes three hours
to tell on screen it means you didn't
have time to edit it just you know it's
like that's the Oscar Wilde I'm sorry I
didn't have time to write you a short
letter and you just it means time and so
what you're seeing is just the the
benefit of all this time to really kind
of reduce it down to like its essence
and they all started out to fat and with
stories that could have wanted them to
have their own movies you know we have
700 animators who are looking for any
opportunity so often to like give like
they're like I know it wasn't in the
original when you when you gave it to me
but I added this little beat with you
know so and and the actors obviously
themselves are improving as we go like
you know ty and Caitlin would improv
whole beats that we were weren't in the
script and and then we ended up kind of
trying to find a place for somewhere so
Thomas let's talk about the music one of
the things that I you know music you
think of the song
you think of a particular chase scene
where there's lots of you know but the
thing that I noticed watching it a
second time was where I think you're
really a master is the very subtle
places where you're looking the like
dories eyes are just staring straight
ahead and the music is not doing
anything very complex at all it's just
that's fairly static yeah but it seems
to me that the the pressure to maybe
want to push too hard on that and yet
you find just the right note so how do
you find those notes to bring that out
oh yeah I guess you you see the larger
arc and that that if there's any one
moment that you think you want underline
you ask yourself if I underlined this
will it take away from a more important
underlining down the line so you and
then you you kind of decide what matters
more where music can help drama more and
if it doesn't need help like in the case
of dory staring out into nothingness and
stillness is your friend as opposed to
describing that or giving some more
story aspect you just you just lay low
and you've been you wait for it for a
moment when it's gonna top it up better
and you can always tell I mean typically
you know we can sit in front of an image
listen to music and we can say we're too
early doing too much and we want to wait
and there was the big thing when when
dory finally meets her parents what was
that a moment right there or was it a
suspended thing that would allow you to
kind of be in that kind of timorous
moment and then a more outgoing moment
when they when they start to twirl so
when you're coming back to a world that
you've composed for before and with a
director you've worked for before did
you go back to Finding Nemo and and
think about what you had done there did
you try to were you consciously trying
to reuse themes or any kind of music or
were you just basically saying no I want
this to be finding dory how did you
approach it
I probably the latter I think Andrew had
kind of very purposely stayed away from
Finding Nemo for the most part other
than a one quote of the tune and I think
we really didn't want to be in Finding
Nemo the
land so much as where where are we with
Dory because it really is a different
movie yeah from the very outset I wanted
it I knew it wasn't coming from a
personal like the first movie came from
a personal issue I had as a father so it
was it came from deep within but now
these cares characters existed like
family members and it was your sort of
going from the outside and I knew there
was all this turmoil and and absence of
inside Dory but I knew her voice wasn't
mine and so I I got a female writer
Victoria Strauss early on to write and I
just knew that that would ground us in a
different point of view and a different
angle and it would it would and if we
were lucky and I think I never really
watched Finding Nemo that much at all
unless we had to reference something
technically and I think he did the same
musically he didn't go back because we
just wanted to honestly find the voice
of dory and and and I thought and I felt
very comfortable that if we found it
honestly it would by its own design be
harmonious with the first one and there
wasn't like some checklist we had to go
off of a reference to make sure we were
feeling like we were in the same family
I thought that would actually trap us
and block us from thinking correctly you
know you find these originals by making
a million mistakes and going like a lot
of different wrong ways and you need to
safely be able to do that with a sequel
as well you should treat it just like an
original so Sigourney Weaver I mean
that's like one of the best gags in the
whole film how did that come about well
she was also a voice of computer and the
mothership of wall-e and I'm you know so
honored to actually know her now and
actually have her phone number and I
didn't want to abuse that privilege and
I thought it would be weird to ask her
to be a voice again but man we just came
up with it one time and we put it in and
it just cracked us up we thought it was
so we did this we do this to ourselves
to kind of crack ourselves up cuz you're
in this movie for so long that we put
things in our screenings sometimes that
we're like there's no way that's gonna
stick because it's so weird but it makes
us laugh even though cuz it's all
internal for so long that we put it in
and we're like oh that's somebody's
gonna say like that's so weird
and then the gag kind of just kept
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
because it's a voiceover and there's no
animation to it we kept waiting because
we were seriously we're thinking it was
going to get pulled out
and if you're gonna ask that favor and
then ya have a cut so we called her it
kind of really at the last minute and I
don't think she's seen it yet but Andrew
Warner he's like kids are gonna know
your name forever for no item out of
context they won't know your history
they won't they're gonna they're gonna
know your name and it's a great name
that's like you did you really get your
mouth around it you know so thank you
all for being here and thank you all for
staying you've enjoyed it thank you